the man who was murdered was just doing
his job this was how sir david amos mp
was described in court the prosecutions
say he was killed in a vicious and
frenzied attack
tom little cuci said this is a case
involving a cold and calculated murder a
murder carried out in a place of worship
a murder carried out because of a warped
and twisted and violent ideology
the parliamentarian had been holding a
constituency surgery at a church in lyon
sea in essex just after midday on the
15th of october the south end west mp
was killed
he suffered 21 stab wounds to his face
arms legs and torso as well as injuries
to both hands that were consistent with
defending himself the knife had a
12-inch blade and allegedly was bought
five years before the incident
the prosecution told the court so
david's death was the result of
sustained and extensive planning
ali harvey alli had allegedly made
reconnaissance trips to the houses of
parliament finchley mp mike fries
constituency surgery and on five
occasions visited the home address of
michael gove
sir david amos's family were visibly
upset at times in court today choosing
to leave the courtroom when the jury
were played the 999 call that was made
on the day of the instant when they
heard details of the alleged attack and
when they were shown the body camera
footage of the moment of arrest
ali habi ali showed no emotion in the
dock as he carefully studied the court
documents he denies murder and planning
a terrorist attack for more than two
years his trial is expected to last
three weeks
ash narendra sky news at the old bailey